Just to explain the gratitude and the
happiness that this brother of ours is
facing just 10 minutes ago he couldn't
stand. Alhamdulillah through your
donations to Bak forever today not only
is he standing but he has a smile on his
face
to each and every one of you who
dignified our brother our father from
donate to forever and help change lives
today.
Asalam alaikum two brothers and sisters
and dear friends. So this was a
interaction that Sneo had after he had a
back and forth with Andrew Tate. Um and
something I saw this video and I thought
to myself subhan Allah it is intriguing
like I don't I looked and I was like
subhan Allah why is he uncomfortable in
this specific position like you know
Sneo's outright you can see if if
somebody has genuine good intentions.
Yeah. Okay, they would talk openly
openly about it. Uh, and that's what
Sneo is doing. You can see in Sneak just
talking about, you know, what he
believes and he's just in to his cause,
etc. But you see Andrew Tate gets very
very uncomfortable. And look, I believe
there's two options here. Either Andrew
Tate has alter ulterior motives or he's
under pressure. He's being threatened.
It can be one of the two. Yeah, we can
assume the best and say, you know, he's
been under pressure. There's been stuff
that he said which is very concerning.
But let's watch this video and look at
what Sneo says and look carefully at
Andrew Tate and his demeanor. Yeah. How
he usually is with confidence, head
high, you know, he has this thing that
he does, etc. Very confident in what he
says. When this is mentioned, he's very
very uh he looks concerned.
>> It's unfortunate reality of the world.
>> So far,
>> I'm not convinced that Trump's doing
anything for America at the like so far
this whole term. Netanyahu visiting five
times. I'm sure you saw that Jerusalem
dinner. the amount of money that he's
sending there. I'm not convinced that
he's putting when we say US, it just
sounds Trump has allegiance to Israel.
They put him their arm around him saying
he's the first Jewish president. I don't
see it long-term benefiting America. I
think all the money and all of his
policies right now are just to benefit.
He just seems like a complete shelf. I'm
not convinced that it it's it's for
America. what you're saying because
every time he sends $3 billion to Israel
and Ted Cruz goes on goes on as a as a
state senator.
>> So you can see Sneo is very like open to
this issue. Okay. When he was supporting
Trump to when he's not and he's having a
dialogue and discussion yes we know
Andrew Tate to be very vocal. He's very
vocal. He gives his opinions. He doesn't
care. He's sometimes unhinged etc.
Over here you can see from his body
language he seems very uncomfortable. he
doesn't want to be involved in the
conversation. Now, there's two options
here. Number one,
um he has ulterior motives and he's just
like, you know what, I don't want to get
involved in this. This going to affect
he knows the power that the Zionist hold
for God's sake, they're controlling the
they're controlling um the president of
the United States. Okay, he's they've
made him Jewish now. Okay, Zionist,
whatever for that matter. But you can
see from his demeanor, which you can
maybe see on the screen here, his head
down. That's not like Andate his head
down looking at his watch. Yep. Not
getting involved with the conversation.
Yeah, you can see like you know he's
he's he's listening. He's looking at the
other side. And the thing is now someone
might come and say, "Oh, you're making a
big deal." No, no, no, no, no. So sorry.
At the end of the day, it may be that
for his case to be dropped or whatever
it is for that matter, the people that
are pulling the strings, it might be
that he was in a situation where he may
have been guilty on certain accusations
that were made against him, allegations,
and they said, "Look, we can drop all of
that. All of that could be buried and
like it never happened. But we need you
to do a and if you don't do a and if you
don't do a this is what's going to
happen because sne doesn't look like
he's concerned about anything or if
there something when somebody's
confident guys when someone's got
nothing to hide they don't care. Do you
get it? There are certain things and
topics like I'll be honest with I talk
about etc. If I had like you know you
know some case on me or whatever etc.
I'll be very careful to what I say.
Somebody who I'm giving the se to, etc.
I would be very careful to what I say
cuz I'm like, "Yo, man, I got dirt. If
this comes out, I'm finished." Somebody
that's got nothing to hide, is bold,
doesn't care. It's fearless. They don't
care, bro. I don't care who thinks what
of me. You come for my family, my dad,
my granddad, my whatever it is. I don't
care. I'm going to speak the truth. And
that someone is dangerous because you
know why? Because it shows that they
have got a clean slate and do they do
not care. Okay? So Andrew Tates and his
demeanor like that, it shows me a lot of
things going on. So either that or
either genuinely he's being a Muslim for
the wrong reasons. So with him blaming
Muslims, terrorist attacks on Muslims
without any factual evidence shows me
that and not only that, like to now that
we're seeing that the UAE, you know,
like certain individuals there are even
involved in Islamophobia, it's shocking
because to them they're justifying it by
saying this is the Muslim Brotherhood or
whatever it is for that matter. these
are extremist individuals. So you can
see Andrew Tate is going down that path.
Is it because he believes he's doing
something good? He believes there are
extremes in Islam, Islamic religion that
Muslims uh taking the religion to the
extreme and he's trying to combat that.
I don't know. I don't know. But what I
can see is there is definitely something
that they may have on him that is
causing him to behave the way he is or
this is all calculated and he's doing
this for one reason, one reason or two.
And that's why you can see the shift in
the gambling and this that and people
losing respect for him because he's
changed his whole thing. He might be
under pressure. Do rest. We do not know.
But that video speaks a lot cuz in other
conversations with other stuff, he's
very jolly. He's very loudspoken. But
when it comes to this Israel situation
and Trump, he's quiet.
I just want to bring that to your
attention. Inshallah. May Allah keep
firm and may Allah allow Andutate to
come back to you know his senses and do
the right thing as a Muslim and we
assume that he's a Muslim still. Till
next time.